it can be easy to imagine that we
possess reasonable social skills because
we know how to maintain conversation
with strangers and every now and then
managed to make a whole table laugh but
his attest far sterner than this
surprising in its ability to trip us up
the challenge of having a pleasant time
with a child
we don't know theoretically speaking
this should be so easy we were all once
kids we know a great deal more than they
do and as far as they're concerned we
hold all the cards
if we felt like it we could buy twenty
six packets of biscuits and go to bed
whenever we wanted yet in reality it's
strangely hard to get at ease around
children we're not already close to
imagine being invited around your boss's
house for lunch and being left alone in
the kitchen island with her moody
ten-year-old son or being introduced
into a playroom with two shy
five-year-old girls the children of a
friend we may swiftly grow will during
ly tongue-tied and inept the reason is
that children are unable to do any of
the normal things that ease social
encounters between adult strangers they
don't ask polite questions about what
we've been up to
they have no feeling for our lives or
what might be important to us they don't
do the news or the weather and they
can't usually tell us much about
themselves and their enthusiasms if we
ask them why they like a toy or a film
they tend to look blank and say they
just like it that's all so for all their
sweetness children present formidable
and fascinating barriers to social
fluidity which is also why they are the
greatest tests for one's mastery of the
arts of charm and kindness we have
across cultural history a few moving
examples of accomplished adults getting
on well with children no tenure marked
that he found nothing more notable in
the life of Socrates the man who more or
less began Western philosophy then that
he was exceptionally gifted at playing
with children and would especially in
his later years spend many hours playing
games and giving them piggy backs and it
suited him well added more Tang for all
actions says philosophy equally become
equally honor a wise man ahi cat king of
France in 1589 to 1610 is remembered as
one of the most benign French monarchs
who also happened to be very sweet
around children on one occasion famously
painted by argh the Spanish ambassador
came to see the king and found him
pretending to be a horse for his
children to ride on rather than
interrupt the game immediately aw he
kept the Ambassador waiting a little
while sending out a strong signal of
where he felt sensible adult priorities
should sometimes lie what's touching in
these cases is that the adult didn't
insist on using their obvious socially
endorsed strengths around children
Socrates didn't opt to deliver lectures
about metaphysics or he cat didn't sit
impassively on a golden throne
discussing how to rule a kingdom they
put aside their well known virtues and
prestige in order to make themselves
vulnerable as one must whenever
friendship is at stake they dare to lay
themselves open to attack by those who
might have described them as silly or
undignified implicitly understanding
that friendship can only emerge when we
let the fragile unadorned parts of us
meet without artifice the fragile
unadorned parts of others furthermore
these two grand men knew how to find
common ground with creatures who were in
so many respects entirely alien to them
Cosmopolitan's of the mind
they imaginatively search for what
unites rather than what divides people
and were able to locate somewhere within
their characters the joys and
excitements of someone who's only been
on earth a few years the socially adept
know that we contain even if only in
Crais embryonic forms all human
possibilities within us which they draw
upon to feel their way into the needs
and points of view of strangers so even
if they happen to be confident they will
know how to be in touch with the more
timid version of themselves even if they
are financially secure they can mobilize
their own experience of anxiety to enter
into the inner world of someone beset by
money worries and even if their careers
have not gone well they can without
bitterness find a part of themselves
that would love to prosper and use this
to engage really with someone whose
professional life has gone very well
indeed the moves that these grand people
made with kids the ones we should all
learn how to make with anyone of
whatever age who we want to bond with
but it's particularly useful that these
were grand people who made neighing
sounds for what so often holds us back
around others and makes us cold when we
deep down long to be close is a fear of
a loss of dignity friendship begins and
loneliness can end when we cease trying
to
press have the courage to step outside
off safety zones and canned air for a
time to look a little ridiculous
did you know that the School of Life is
actually a place ten places in fact
campuses all over the world from
Melbourne to London Taipei to Istanbul
with classes and books and lots more
please click on the link below to
explore more